deux caméras beaucoup quel argent mais pourquoi
tu dois être si impitoyable parce que l'un des
défis de raconter l'histoire était que je
n'avais pas facile ici avec facile, il était
vraiment important pour moi que nous ayons
raison de son histoire, pensez que d'abord être
dur Jason Mitchell jouait facile,
il est incroyable et j'étais des trafiquants de dope
qui ont la compétence très propre eazy-e
non seulement je peux lire l'humaniser
mais je vous fais aussi connaître le
défi ultime en tant qu'acteur pour vraiment incarner
cette personne d'abord en direct  performance pour de
vrai pour de vrai en direct, nous avons la
bénédiction de toute cette famille quand je l'
ai vu pour la première fois, je m'ai donné les frissons que
vous voulez réellement comprendre en profondeur qui est
cet individu dans son ensemble, donc ça
va être bien nous voulons être  impliqué
dans cette vie de gangster, pouvons-nous aller au
moment où vous vous asseyez dans le film,
vous allez jurer que c'est facile qu'est-ce que vous
avez dans ce sac, vous vous moquez de moi, vous
ne pouvez pas prendre ça dans le bus ayant la
tâche de raconter l'histoire  et l'héritage
qu'il a laissé c'était moi  important que je comprenne
bien son nom et les garçons qui
arrivent